selon les milieux sociaux il ya
plusieurs modèles de coupe il ya un
modèle de couple idéal mais qu'il est
très difficile à atteindre et selon les
milieux sociaux on vit pas du tout le
couple de la même façon et dans les
milieux populaires où le modèle de
couple reste encore très fusionnelle une
séparation c'est une catastrophe
identitaire d'accueillir les personnes
s'effondre parce que là la l'identité
personnelle il fondé avec l'autre et en
complément une complémentarité alors que
dans les couches moyennes on est plus
sur un modèle du couple duo où chacun
qu'une certaine autonomie peut avoir des
activités qui lui sont propres de
loisirs ou autre la séparation est
toujours douloureux mais c'est pas la
même catastrophe
donc il ya plusieurs modèles de couple
qui fonctionne le couple entente elle
reste extrêmement valoriser mais selon
les milieux et les situations on n'a pas
forcément a affaire au même modèle de
foncière
[Musique]